I just picked up some tampons and y'all  are probably thinking Dylan where are  you gonna put those they're not for me  but this last weekend I was in the  restroom and the girl in the stall next  to me was like hey do you have a tampon  and I froze I was like sorry no but in  that moment I decided you know what I'm  always gonna have one on hand women  supporting women  now I confess that I have no personal  first-hand knowledge of what goes on  inside a woman's bathroom because I'm a  man if I had to guess I would suspect  that a woman shouting to a stranger in  the next stall asking for a tampon is  not a normal occurrence it reminds me of  the Seinfeld scene where Elaine asks her  stall neighbor for some toilet paper  something that I've never personally  heard or seen anyone do in real life  ever and if I were ever on the receiving  end of such a request in a public  bathroom I would consider it a  horrendous breach of public bathroom  etiquette